in five four three two one
welcome to this [ __ ] episode again of
genius brain podcast the [ __ ] card
ran out earlier so we have to redo these
conversations and pretend like we
[ __ ] care
we probably spoke for about thirty
minutes already
yeah it was fun it was well we've been
hanging out for over thirty minutes so
we've been talking nonstop yeah well we
have a very special guest today we have
our little friend Jason Chen thanks for
having me man
that's right theez me you are actually
not the shortest youtuber out there who
is the shortest there's the funny thing
is there's three youtubers that are that
are short that are very famous it was
David Choi oh yeah David Choi it was Tim
yeah and then you I've always wanted to
see what it would look like if all three
you gone to a fistfight I wanna see
who's gonna come out on top I put my
money I think physically you're the
strongest one I think David is actually
the craziest person but Tim is Thai and
he has big-ass [ __ ] hands Tim's hands
are like legit almost the size of my
head I probably just run dude no you
have to fight this is a deathmatch bull
there's no choice its battle royale
there can only be one short youtuber
okay okay cuz you learn the motivation
man because the funny thing is with Tim
like even though Tim is a shorter guy
he's always seemed a lot taller to me
yes a gas personality we out of the
three of you who's the shortest is it
Tim I feel like we're all the same
height yeah what is your height for the
people that don't know I'm a hair under
five four five four so if I wake up in
the morning I'm over five four you are
5'4 then that's just your spine
compressing things eh okay that's what
happens though like I'm six I'm like six
two when I wake up man I'm go down to 6
1 but my wingspan is shorter than my
height so I'm like a t-rex oh really yes
that's just the asian body is it baby
Tyson dude is what you are baby isn't it
cuz my torsos like very long compared to
my limbs when I sit down I'm taller than
like that's I think that's that's how I
tell black people I'm like I'm taller
than you when I sit down cuz josh is
like six something I guess Josh can
touch his knees standing up
jacopo states wingspan 7 feet tall
yeah the rest of his body didn't grow as
well he had scoliosis so it doesn't
count cause he had a fix his spine and
yeah so I'm like I'm taller did you Josh
that's like deceptively long arms yeah
that's crazy it's [ __ ] ridiculous how
long is honor but that goes to show that
like you don't have to be tall to also
get a girlfriend and all that stuff
because Tim's married you have a
long-term relationship I don't know
about David but he seems like he's a
ladies man I wish did know the little
David Oh David Choi at me I was like
kind of my short guy already dirty
everyone knows you're with someone um
and I think that's all that's all fake
dude see I'm talking to girls I don't I
don't know you got with a girl when you
were the fattest - it was the chickens
real game that was the best I you know
I've never actually seen David Choi
around a girl I don't know what it's
like um I seen him
I seen him drunk in front of women I
feel like I've seen him around girls
like in Asia like on those trips oh yeah
he's brave he's very brave yeah he
doesn't care definitely braver than me
sure yeah he just walks up to him is it
easier to talk to women when you're in
Asia though because I feel like a lot of
those girls now already know who you are
not anymore he is not this is before he
met his girlfriend it's it's easier in
the sense that there's less pressure
because first of all you don't live
there so oh yeah yeah that's if they say
no like you know you just go back to
you're gonna go back home anyways yeah
jetlag gives me courage that gives
because alcohol gave me a lot of courage
though the alcohol gets encouraged as
well yeah cuz you just say whatever you
want you're like completely inhibited
and you just uninhibited and just go why
you just go out and you say whatever and
see what happens
and also back then you could kind of
blame it on it you can be like oh I was
just yeah I mean today it's not an
excuse anymore but ten years ago people
he just had a little too much it was a
little dry and he grabbed your ass he's
[ __ ] went under your skirt I pretend
that he was a lampshade
because he drank a little bit we had we
had a show back in the day have you guys
had shows together before yeah couple
yeah a couple but how did you got more
you want part of that that [ __ ]
disastrous Australia's show I like that
when I went the year after
was that a disaster - no really yeah
same same same venue anybody I believe
it was the same promoter what was it
what was the event called uh I don't
remember it was so long ago what the
[ __ ] but like I heard about that one you
guys didn't get paid out and all that
stuff I actually got paid well but a lot
of other people here before is like way
more people and I don't think pick up I
did one totally unrelated to you guys
but it was supposed to be like the
VidCon of Australia it was it was done
by this guy that does events and he was
such a half-assed businessman and he was
panicking the whole entire time I
actually got into a fight with him like
a yelling match not a fist fight but I
made that [ __ ] back down because I
felt like you know like sometimes do you
ever get this when like there's guys
that think they can have one on you and
then they can kind of like act like
aggressive yeah all the way all the time
and I just thought it happened cuz I'm
such a little [ __ ] well that's that's I
think that's the thing like he was like
a taller older white guy oh and I think
there was he basically there was a
miscommunication because like there was
supposed to be some media coverage and
then there was a news reporter and then
all the youtubers went down there and
then he wanted all of us to kind of be
there to talk to the news and nothing
was it was so disorganized so [ __ ] up
right
no one knew were was those it was
literally like at anicon it was like
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] it was ran all by
volunteers that had no chain of command
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
they had a whole convention center
barely anybody was there he was
panicking cuz he thought that the
youtubers alone could bring everybody
he's all like I spent millions on this
which is [ __ ] complete [ __ ]
because if you did spend millions on a
convention you're an idiot
it was a very small one so just from
what I watched I was like this guy's
lying off of his ass he's panicking he's
yelling at everyone saying like I'm
losing
millions here and all this stuff and um
anyways so like the he wanted like news
coverage hoping that like somehow you
know this will be reported on news and
all of a sudden like droves of people
will come in and I'm like this is stupid
it's not a part of the contract so I'm
sitting there and I'm like a man we've
been here for 30 minutes what's going on
like are we gonna get interviewed or do
they need us cuz I'm gonna go back to
the green room and then I didn't get a
response and I saw him like zigzagging
around the floor so I was like [ __ ] this
and I started walking up and people
started following me so when I was up
there up to the stage or up to the grill
I went back to the green room so I went
I went to go to the lounge area so I was
in the lounge area like and in that's
where all the youtubers were there was
like Smosh there was remember alphaCAT
there was like our group there was like
you to like like australian youtuber is
like Choni and all them and they're all
just hanging out like just waiting right
cuz we were supposed to have meet and
greets and shows and all this and it was
just so [ __ ] up but anyways he came up
and then while I'm on my [ __ ] laptop
and working on my [ __ ] he just starts
like yelling at me and he's all like man
you know how much you know how much I'm
spending millions here and all there's a
and then I turn around I said who the
[ __ ] are you [ __ ]
cuz I didn't know he was the person that
put it all together he just stopped and
I was like who the [ __ ] are you yeah I
was like what the [ __ ] do you think
you're doing yelling at me like this
[ __ ] he was I put all this together I
was like you're a [ __ ] idiot
all these [ __ ] volunteers together
you're not paying anybody I don't give a
[ __ ] if you're losing made millions I
was like don't [ __ ] come up to me
doing that [ __ ] you know I started
yelling back at him I don't think he was
like expecting know that somebody would
yell back at him and I started berating
his ass and I put my [ __ ] finger in
his face and I was just like one inch
away I was spitting on them dude I felt
great when when people act aggressively
like that I feel like it just brings
something out of my soul
like I want to choke this person and
make them die like I was like I was just
in shock that he was yelling at me so
the only thing I knew was to be a
gorilla back right like and I just
started yelling at this [ __ ] and
then everyone was just like holy [ __ ]
and he's like he's like he's like yeah I
put all this together and all I wanted
was five minutes from you and I was like
we'll learn how to [ __ ] respect
people next time and I just walked away
and then later we we were going through
the same door he grabbed the door he
opened it for me to come through and he
was like please come through and I was
like that's right [ __ ] you [ __ ]
respectful but you know what I'm so
stupid because after that we had a
contract where they paid half up front
and half later they never ended up
paying the other half but everyone else
got paid eventually because I think he
just you know but was it worth it though
was it really worth me not getting paid
the rest of my money probably not I
don't think I'd do that again I think it
was uh done gracefully and rightfully so
I think you would have been way better
than me I think if somebody started
yelling at me and I didn't know that
that was a promoter I probably just what
a socked he was the guy that ran like he
was the one that funded it did all that
stuff I didn't know that I thought he
was just some one of the minions and
volunteers I didn't know that but it
doesn't matter like you it's even worse
that if you're the owner of this and
this is how you're talking to people
that you hired that's worse it's even
worse and in I'm like men just because
you're being incompetent and stupid
you're trying to take it out on someone
what if I wasn't aggressive like what if
I was like like Jason I have a really
short story for you guys so in 2013 I
went to Malaysia and Singapore to do
like a couple shows with Clara and we
had a full band and then the guy we had
previously worked with him and
everything was cool so we didn't like
four shows in like two weeks and he's
just never paid us oh no Dan and I just
accepted it you just left it out there
there was I wish I could be like I I
know I mean we'll our
we call but I mean like there's nothing
we could have done you know like well
sure we could have hired a lawyer but I
was just like let's just give it up man
this podcast is brought to you by public
Rec my friends think about the most
comfortable pair of sweatpants you've
ever worn in your life
they're probably raggedy as hell and I'm
guessing and I'm betting that you wish
that your regular pants were as
comfortable as those sweatpants I'm
always wondering you know why can't they
just make both happen well guess what
public Rec has got your back with the
all-day everyday pant Sun its pants that
look dope but have the comfort the
comfort my friends and in my opinion the
comfort of sweatpants and that's what
I'm looking for because I'm not trying
to be uncomfortable at all but I don't
want to look trashy as well and the all
day everyday pen has that for you well
let me tell you something really cool
about these pants they're the first
sweats that have waste and inseam sizing
so whether you're short tall or
somewhere in between they fit perfectly
the design details like the elastic
waistband with internal drawstring the
two deep front zipper pockets and the
faux front fly for a more formal look
they got you son they got that comfort
that casualness and also the flyness as
well and that's why I've Rock the sweat
pants baby so check it out right now you
can get an exclusive offer just for our
listeners go to public read comm slash
brain today and get 10% off your first
pair of they're all day every day pants
automatically applied at checkout and
always with free us shipping and free
returns don't sleep on this rare
opportunity to get a discount that's
public wreck our EC spelled our EC comm
slash brain for 10% off that's wreck
once again spelled our EC dot-com slash
brain for 10% off your order
but yeah so like in your situation right
like what if he did that to you I don't
know maybe it's an insecurity of mine or
something but I feel like when anybody
that's not Asian tries to bully me I
I have to go a thousand times harder if
they're Asian if they were a Asian it's
different you know and maybe it's it's
weird because I feel like I have to go a
thousand times harder and be even more
aggressive than them because I want them
to know not to [ __ ] with us so I feel
like I have all of Asia
[ __ ] 1.9 billion people on my
shoulders saying don't don't [ __ ]
back down to this assclown you know you
remember we're in Paris and they do it
also by size like for example when we
were in Paris there's a bunch of people
outside of the Eiffel Tower they want
they want to sell you [ __ ] right well
there's those like glow [ __ ] or whatever
and they're coming up to like Casey and
everybody else like you know buy this
[ __ ] and super aggressively but then I'm
like 6:162 they they come up to me and
I'm just like nah and they just walk
away but there's also a size thing to it
because if you're a smaller guy people
always think that they could just Punk
you maybe that's what it is
so like I'm not that big I'm actually I
think on a smaller side just compared to
like Westerners right I'm five seven so
like yeah I feel like I I went
throughout life having to like I have
short man complex even though within
Asians I'm just average size but like I
felt like I had to stick up to my stick
up for myself and be extra aggressive to
compensate for the bullying so then like
because it's it's rewarded me positively
so if I'm extra aggressive to the point
where like oh [ __ ] this guy I could lose
a finger from this guy or whatever then
they then they just maybe they talk and
then I'm like okay cool I don't have to
deal with anything it's so so funny
because I feel like there's like
cultural difference too because I know a
guide that um he had a well he's pretty
well-off right now he sold a number one
his parents are already well-off but
then he made his own company in clothing
sold that off made millions of [ __ ] but
prior to that he had another company
where he was doing I forgot what the
business was exactly that he was doing
but lost story short his business
partner stole millions from him oh no
this [ __ ]
I kid you not
I didn't I didn't know him at this time
but everybody told me the same story
about him he's like a super nice guy
he's like a nice little small family and
everything now but they said that he
disappeared for [ __ ] two years to
look for this guy in China
oh my disappeared for two you just you
gonna kill him I think he's killing oh
my what I mean he has all that money why
doesn't he hire a [ __ ] assassin like
well he didn't cuz at the time the guy
stole everything from me also he didn't
have anything he reinvented himself and
he made millions again Oh two years
stole everything from him and he hunted
him down in China and he found and he
found this fool turns out that dude blew
all the but of course yeah and the guy
was a [ __ ] bum so he couldn't even
get his revenge on him so he was just
like [ __ ] he wanted to beat the living
and then whatever money he had left he
used that money to go find and hunt this
dude down maybe that was why he
reinvented himself because he was like I
wasted two years this time yeah I could
have been working on another business
yeah well he you know he sure as hell
did well after that he could have been
food vlogging for those two years that's
a lot of food in China just vlog his
process of trying to find this time I
know he's a lot older than us but this
yeah YouTube wasn't around then this was
like in his like I think late 20s early
30s so he's like in his 40s now so when
this all happened I was uh this was
[ __ ] seven years ago or some [ __ ]
like that maybe yeah
six or seven years ago so I don't know
if I'd do it again
I don't know hardly I don't really get
bullied you don't get bullied you don't
go outside dude no I mean thank you no
one really bullies me like seriously
like people will like lightheartedly
kind of but no one comes in my face and
been like screamed at me or anything
like that
he also grew up in Arcadia to write in
medical area but I mean like he's
talking about like a show like I've
never been in that situation no one's
ever spoken to you condescendingly cuz
maybe I'm just a sensitive [ __ ] and
it's probably not that bad but then I
might take it that bad but I just don't
like people raising their voice I've
just seen people yeah talk
condescendingly to my girlfriend and
that kind of triggers me but oddly no
one really does that to me I mean I mean
I can't really remember it like David
kind of makes fun of me like you guys
but it's like it's not
like no no cuz we're friends aggressive
kind of like I feel threatened kind of
way yeah you know why maybe because you
don't do things so for example like if
you're in that group right you would
have just waited until you got orders
instead of just saying well [ __ ] you and
you walked away so yeah things that
maybe upset people probably also do is
because we are comics so people feel
like they could joke around with that
when they don't have that rapport with
us right and that's where a lot of the
times that that kind of [ __ ] goes awry
also too is because we put ourselves out
there in that type of sense so people
feel like they have to match that energy
when they really don't have to right
we're there's this online personality
there's this camera personality and yeah
I'm very similar to my camera
personality but it's like those are
performance parts right and sometimes
people kind of they blur those lines a
lot and it causes a lot of problems of
frictions like for example like well is
that a show and we were taking this
photo right you know I'm like a joking
ass do I joke around a lot and you know
I give people hugs or whatever this dude
as we were taking this photo he comes up
and as we're taking the photo he [ __ ]
grabs my ass immediately I slapped him
upside then did you [ __ ] bulb slap
his face I slapped him upside the head
falling from the blocking force I don't
[ __ ] touch me dude what did he
apologized but I was pissed I was like
cuz he's trying to be funny right and
it's like if Bart touched my ass that's
okay I know Bart doesn't my brother you
know what I mean you don't touch me like
that I don't [ __ ] know you dude like
it's like that same concept of like
would you touch a girl like that you
probably wouldn't and if you did you
probably should get [ __ ] up too but
people blur those lines a lot right
because they're too comfortable yeah a
little too comfortable you know that
makes sense because if someone came up
and grabbed my ass that would just be
really random would just be like they
would just have something wrong with
them yeah what didn't it be
understandable with you I kind of get it
is it gonna be funny yeah like hey buddy
yeah let's do gay jokes yeah yeah that's
that's really what it is and you know
I'm like and it wasn't like I thought
about slapping she's just automatic
lights went by this is what I would do
reflexes I just [ __ ] squeeze my ass
thank you but like what the [ __ ] was
that about feel good honestly it felt
like a Trump grope like
like a claw you know what I mean I feel
like some people do that [ __ ] though to
like get you to remember them hmm
I don't even remember his face I don't
remember anything about him I just like
you're the guys left if he if he told me
like I'm the guy that grabbed her ass
then I probably remember him but if I
don't remember his face at all
whatsoever at all it's hard to remember
people men because you meet so many
people there's somebody that I'm I saw
recently now this person I know that I
had rapport with her and cuz I probably
I did a college show enough times with
her there that I met her a couple of
times I think she was one of the
organizers that brought me out well she
lives in LA now and I saw her I see her
a couple of times around this area like
then I live in and no idea what the [ __ ]
she is but she knows who I am so every
time I see her I'd have to introduce I
don't remember her name I don't know
what college I saw her from and I don't
know why we have such good rapport well
it's hard because in one meet-and-greet
you'd meet someone well there's 3 to 800
people that show up sometimes yeah so
you try giving that kind of attention
and then remembering someone that you
met for about 1 minute
maybe 2 minutes max it's difficult dude
yeah even even if you have interactions
with like an event organized a organ
organizer that like brought you out or
whatever and you spend a day with them
right like we're meeting thousands of
people every year so and on top of that
they don't know how much drugs I've done
yeah a lot of the times I'm like I'm
sorry I don't remember you but like I'm
it's not because I'm mr. famous it's cuz
I have bad memory dude in society I
think I went to a Knicks boxing thing
maybe like four times before I
remembered like the other guy's name
yeah it's good yeah I just don't
remember you have to really put it to
memory
yes we're just kind of like in the multi
the multiple times like see how I've
learned to do it now it's like if I
really vibe with somebody at a show
and I'm like oh we could be friends when
I take their contact in my phone I give
them a nickname like there's a wonderful
name yeah so it'll be like Jessica
[ __ ] eyes [ __ ] around she's not
even Asian
it helps you remember that's why she had
really really tiny eyes and she was from
Alabama like I remember so I'll put the
college that they were from like some
kind of physical attribute that I
remember about them or something weird
that they did and then it helps me
remember them a lot because I'll tell
them like yo when you hit me up if you
ever come to LA y'all should go grab a
meal because you were so hospitable
towards me when I went there so I but I
have to do that I have to be like James
bad breath Kim people take you up on
that not a lot I think they're maybe
they're a little apprehensive about it
but the hard part is when people come
when I go out to a show I'm Yours right
because that's what I'm dinner did yeah
but when I'm here I'm still working yeah
so it's it's hard to kind of match it's
hard because I feel bad when friends
come visit LA and I can't give them the
same type of like hospitality that they
give me when I'm in their city cuz um
it's like it's like our buddy Nancy from
Hawaii right like every time we're in
Hawaii she's like always hanging out
with us driving us around like and then
for us when she comes down like I could
probably meet up for like a dinner or
two but then I can't do the same thing
where I'm like hanging out with her yeah
and that's the same for a lot of people
and I'm like man that kind of it kind of
sucks because I feel like I'm not being
a cool friend yeah where I can do the
same amount of effort and it's only
because when we're in LA like we're just
close to our work so close that like our
regular lives don't allow that yeah yeah
cuz for you when you do music I mean
first of all you were an accountant
first before you became an audition
right which is such a weird from numbers
to love yeah yeah that's such a weird
trajectory did you were you always
singing since you were little kiddos I
so know that happened I started singing
in a senior year end of senior year in
high school
oh really how'd you figure that out I
was terrible I was singing I just wanted
a creative way to ask this girl the prom
and I know you're really singing yeah
why just [ __ ] ask her because
I was really insecure I was really
insecure just tiptoe in all the pictures
no I would like I would wear like Air
Force Ones right and then I would like
tiptoe again in the picture I would like
you know like you do the thing where
you're like you're not tiptoeing
outwardly yeah for my whole life I would
do that a nice height at the age of 12
yeah I was insecure man I was like if I
ask if she's gonna say no I gotta think
of some creative way I didn't want to
hold that thought really quick because
okay cuz learning how to sing mmm it
takes time dude
laughs it's like it's almost like saying
like I want to get my six-pack first so
she can't deny this yeah what it means
for her cuz you're doing something wrong
I think good thing is I I kind of figure
if you do something that you're not good
at it's more of a statement than doing
something you're good at like you're a
good singer and you go sing to someone
it means nothing cuz you're a good
singer you're just showing off at that
point
oh I get what you're saying so if I was
gonna do something now maybe I'd like
dance cuz I can't dance for crap so you
it shows like you're vulnerable
yeah those that like what you're willing
to do challenge to get her yeah it was I
was going to sweet route cuz I'm not a
tall jock so I couldn't do this I had to
be a tall jog you just [ __ ] make her
laugh okay I'm calm yeah that's the time
I was 17 and okay insecure I'm not
talking [ __ ] to a 17 year old I'm just
trying to like I deserve she deserves
that
I mean I would say okay so that got you
into it but it worked and then all
through yeah I mean yeah you got her I
did what do you do record a track or did
you sink toward Isis sing to her in my
car while we were waiting to back out
cuz we I took her ice-skating and like
in Pasadena actually and it was backed
up the eggs that was backed up yeah and
we couldn't back out of the car at all I
know it was a song it was actually a
song called holiday by this R&B singer
back then called Reynard Silva wait you
guys were already dating I don't know so
how did you get your car I asked her to
go ice skating
so she said yeah yeah she's already
interested in you bro you didn't have to
do this anything should be ice skating
with you so this is super this is super
complicated she had already said yes to
someone else he stole her away but I
didn't know that she said yes to someone
else
so the singing is what put it over T's I
gotta go with this guy yeah like a
vibrato cuz he could pop do this [ __ ] on
my [ __ ] yeah you're pretty interesting
story yeah so she was already she
already said yes is somebody else that
she decided to go with you instead okay
so this is the long this is the longer
version she I didn't know she had said
yes to someone else so I asked her she
said yes then a couple days later she
told me she only said yes because I put
her in a situation where she couldn't
say no but she needed to go with this
guy so I was like okay but then we'd
hung out every day during spring break
so he changed her mind again and then
she was like how about I go with you but
you let me have one dance with him a
whole Mike I was like alright whatever
you know so then what happened was any
options she disappeared for the whole
prom except for the last song so it's
the [ __ ] last song and I didn't like
she goes to dance with him and I'm just
like oh dude this sucks this is a
[ __ ] last song of problem I'm sitting
here by myself yeah so it was just
looking back it's pretty funny but at
the time it was pretty sad that's
hilarious dude yeah so basically the
music is what's changed her heart and
that's why you continue to pursue music
so you can get [ __ ] did you end up
dating with her uh yeah she became her
girlfriend we dated for a while in
college I always tell people with the
same [ __ ] dude and I've said this is day
one at least you're honest with it every
time I talked to a [ __ ] artist right
who do that's dancing or music they go
when I was a kid and there's a guy not
girls go no the kid I've heard this
[ __ ] one little [ __ ] c-sharp and I
was like this is from you you wanted
[ __ ] and that's why you picked up the
guitar that's why you sang that is and
there's no shame in that they used to do
that [ __ ] back in the olden days where
you had that guy sitting on a wall the
Jester with the curly hat playing his
little lady
yeah milady can I play something about
my flute for you she starts taking off
her clothes ancient ancient [ __ ] get in
remedy dude and I like that that you're
honest cuz that's why I picked up the
guitar she didn't tell same [ __ ]
reason and it worked
I don't
why I never associated music with
getting girls because I just grew up
with it it was like a family thing like
my parents were music
oh that's right yeah yeah yeah yeah my
mom was a musician too yeah but I mean
violin doesn't get you girls I never
lose mine yeah I mean the other
violinist do I liked R&B and all that
stuff too but I had such a wide range of
music that I was just thinking it was
like another way to express myself and I
that's probably why to get into like
deep into singing and things like that
either because it seems like singing
he's very it just there's a lot of
romance to it oh yeah sure
I mean for you to I feel like I mean
that's such a late start start to make
Europe and Arcadia there's no like it's
aspiring singers there and everyone's
trying to like be a doctor get SAT
tutoring and stuff like that did you did
you did you learn about music through
your mom then violin so classically Mike
my parents were like making me do music
but I never really enjoyed classical
music classical music's dull it's I mean
it's dope but as a kid that's not not
fun it's I'd like to say violin is kind
of like baseball
I see like unless you're like number one
in the world like you're like a concert
violinist like you need like an
orchestra to play with right my friend's
a really good violinist but he was
forced into it like North Korean style
so the taught the aged when he turned 18
his mom was like you could quit violin
he went into the back yard got lighter
fluid and [ __ ] lit that [ __ ] in
flames and he says it was the most
satisfying thing that's [ __ ] crazy
and I was like why did you do that dude
you're so [ __ ] good man and that's
just hell expensive yeah I would have
done that if my violin wasn't expensive
because violins are expensive man yeah
he was like it was the most satisfying
thing he's like I'm never gonna touch
any of that [ __ ] ever again and I'm like
oh I wish I would have continued piano
because I can't remember to play that
[ __ ] I wish I learned piano instead of
violin honestly and it's it's kind of
sad because my mom was a piano teacher
but we couldn't get along when she was
trying to teach me that's difficult man
when you're learning from your own
parents yeah yeah you gotta go somewhere
else so interesting could you start a
music so late did you did you sell
teacher did you get a less have never
take actually I took a lesson like
randomly last year just because I was
curious what people tea
but not completely self-taught learned
by trial and error I like saying
incorrectly got like vocal nodes and
just kind of longer it out you got vocal
notes briefly yeah how long did it take
you to like start syncing comfortably in
public and recording that [ __ ] um not
that long like like a year or so
probably that's crazy that you had vocal
notes though that's that's that sucks uh
how did you develop what they weren't
serious like I didn't eat surgery I just
needed a rest how could you tell that
you got it I'm gonna go look at a
specialist did you feel funny or what
was assigned that madam my voice was
just always really tired it's kind of
like if if your knee is fine when you
walk around but you jog like one block
and you're like my knee hurts
something's wrong hmm so you check it
out so every time I'm saying you're like
something's not right like normally I
could sing for like two hours
but I'll sing like two minutes and I'll
I'll feel really tired oh there's a
short I was like you see for two up well
jason has really we I call him like the
boy with the [ __ ] you have like a
compressor in your [ __ ] vocal vocal
through I don't understand because like
you could control your notes so if you
see him record his track yeah his
[ __ ] waves are like this it's like
this little solid [ __ ] wave and it
never changes and every time he seems
like a new note he goes I don't like the
way that is and you see his wave
waveforms are you talking about Bros
exactly they do that I do it so much
that I kind of get used to it but yeah
it's such an odd thing that you do
though because like I know like
everybody like for example somebody who
has a trouble controlling the power and
their voice when they record in the
booth is [ __ ] Joseph Vincent oh yeah
he is a he [ __ ] screams into the mic
I think it was this was years ago though
but he when I remember when I saw him
recording I was like he didn't know how
to record on a mic he did understand how
to pull it back so it would just be so
abrasive you know so that it's it's
interesting you bring that up because
performing and recording is completely
different a hundred percent is a
freaking panty-dropper performer wise
you know I mean I mean I'm sure he's a
lot better at recording now because he
he has a said about his place and a
record was there like like like being
able to perform with acoustics right
like just acoustic guitar acoustic vocal
whatever
in a room that that that you can hear
like in a small space without a mic or
whatever um not really it's like when
you record something you have so many
takes but you have infinite takes
basically right but you have if you're
if you're punching in a line you have to
remember how you sing it previously oh
that's what David said like I remember I
know this is how I have to sing it but
if you do layers or status or harmonies
you guys sing it a specific maybe area
or whatever if you perform it you just
go all out for one one time if you mess
up you move on
so like I'm a much worse live performer
than him mmm but I mean I can't say
anymore because he he's probably
improved a lot through the years but in
the studio I'm a lot more seasoned and
like knowing like how far the mic needs
to be when I need to lay back when I
need to like add breath or whatever yeah
yeah that studio recording is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] than I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] I
hate I hate recording you like live
better yeah cuz you get away with a lot
more things totally yeah yeah if you
just get away with anything and
everything especially if you just have
like a couple effects on it and you have
some reverb to it you're fine should be
a car karaoke specialist because when
you record in a booth what will happen
is you it just picks up every little
nuance in your voice right so if you're
flat if you're sharp it's highly
apparent obviously you can Melodyne it
which is fine but it bothers me a lot it
always bothers me but I'm like oh I
guess that wasn't the right key that I
was singing this whole [ __ ] time and
then when I put the track on I'm like
I'm [ __ ] flat I had no idea I had no
idea until I start recording yeah and
then also when you when you release it
that way it means you've had infinite
takes yeah and had time to change and
polish with it so how can you perform
what you just recorded you put it a half
a step down and you're [ __ ] you just
do it man even if the octaves highest
[ __ ] you should do it yeah not me do it
up but that [ __ ] [ __ ] a couple
octaves down and I'm pretty much good to
go
you can't you can't dance while you sing
dance like when I'm not singing dance
while I say madad spirit yeah do you
perform when you performed you perform
with uh like a
not an orchestra but a band or do you do
tracks
I do neither I usually didn't do an
acoustic set like a piano player guitar
player
oh because wait a band is a huge
production man like your dear depending
on like five or six people to do
perfectly and most of your [ __ ] is
international right because you're
[ __ ] Alicia so she's like some
college shows and stuff I remember like
seven plus years ago I was in Malaysia
and I went to this like hole-in-the-wall
Chinese restaurant got some [ __ ] good
ass Hainan chicken and you're like
picture was on the wall next to the
[ __ ] toilet and I was like what the
hell and I had to send it to this guy
and in like a next day I see him on a
[ __ ] bus stop and I'm like what the
[ __ ] dude this guy's a megastar in Asia
I think I had a had a tour there that
specific time so you probably just ran
into that yeah yeah but you're not in
billboards here like that's a big
[ __ ] see that's the cool part when
I'm sure you - when when like youtubers
American youtubers go to like Asia I
never got on a billboard but we go to
like their top radio station oh we go to
like the top like yes news outlets
that's true you know when we come when
we go to like New York we just go to
like whatever schools you know yeah yeah
usually we'll go to like power more like
kiss-fm or any of that stuff so that's
it's it's like and the excitement level
they have they're like when you perform
live like Asia crowds are just way
better
they just way more excited taiwanese
justin bieber do this with you it's just
justin cheaper do so when you perform
out there you do you hire or do you
bring like like a team or like like you
yeah it's a crown i just go with one
guitar player one piano player and then
they play guitar and piano why are you
seeing yeah
and it's all cover songs originals or
what covers an original here how long's
your set it depends usually the longest
i've done is like an hour and a half
generally it's a holly five minute you
sing for a [ __ ] hour and a half t my
voice would be tired you should play a
game of mafia in between so I usually
sing every [ __ ] funny 15 songs you
sing
15 [ __ ] songs that's like full songs
yeah
but that ends up being like an hour and
a half your voice in your voice doesn't
get tired I get tired after like three
or four songs it gets tired but it runs
like you man I make it too if I get too
much extra [ __ ]
wait so you so most people when they
perform they'll do like a they won't do
the whole song they'll do like you know
like [ __ ] a hook verse hook or
whatever and then they'll stop you do
the whole like four minutes are usually
or or if it or if it's a maybe like a
medley I'll do like verse hook but then
it'll still be like three or four
minutes damn damn you see that's you
worked extra hard that's why I like
having less people because if I get
tired
the piano player guitar player can like
speed up slow down like whatever I can
just look at them you like right let's
do one more let's like do one less it's
easy to communicate all right like the
whole band then you're just stuck with
it right especially if the drummer just
starts off way too slow or way too fast
you just screwed like the whole song is
just ruined you have been so consistent
uploading on youtube since the day you
started you don't ever get fatigued I'm
fatigued all the time yeah but you don't
miss [ __ ] though you know Martin he's
discipline as a mother he doesn't miss
anything he just keeps going cuz I got
fatigue that disappeared for two years
so that's a thing not to we're on we're
on the same depression level yeah I I
get depressed you men
yeah but you don't stop it was not
working though yeah you're addicted to
[ __ ] money you know what it is
wait you when I met you you were moving
boxes are you loading boxes right oh
yeah I was working a nine-to-five JLo
defied I was working at the warehouse
yep I I was I was doing accounting and I
live in Arcadia and my job was in
Century City yeah so what that means is
I woke up at 4:30 yeah I Drive to work
get there at 6:00 and I clock out at 7
p.m.
[ __ ] man drive back two hours get back
on nine right and I'd make like 2 grand
every two months two weeks yeah so it's
kind of like I see it like like I've
been through like I understand
whole fatigue the burnout especially the
creative like it's so hard for me to
write because I have no inspiration when
I do like covers can I write you song
but yeah dude I'm not sure I'll make her
next album please
yep I wrote a song about boba I think I
think you guys gonna not like it but
song called stinky tofu pesto he's
kidding no that shouldn't be [ __ ]
funny dude
but what I mean is like the alternative
right I think like thinking about how
much worse that was and how dead-end
that was just be like full for the
opposite it's not like being grateful
see cuz I mean I'm it's I've been
through you know [ __ ] jobs and yeah in
like same situation like I used to live
in El Monte not that El Monte is a [ __ ]
situation but I was I was living with
Bart's dad and he was letting me rent a
room from his house woke up at you know
six drove to work hour and a half did
the same thing but like you know just
doing it for so long I forgot what I had
to go through yeah I don't think I've
ever forgotten Z so you're still
traumatized where I'm like I'm just kind
of like I don't know man I'm in the
moment I think what it is I'm not
thinking back at how hard it used to be
like it'll come in from time to time but
I'm very much not afraid of the past or
anything like that reason why I'm so
curious about it is because um music is
such I mean for me anyways when I you
know this all this stuff is very
emotional like definitely able to do
that sure so like if it was something as
simple as punching in numbers and doing
that type of stuff I could I could go
through the fatigue cuz I could just
shut my brain off true and just go
through very robotic yeah and if whether
I'm angry or sad I could still get that
work done but if I was like pissed off
or upset it's super hard for me to
create art that's the heart oh man
it's it's going to that point sometimes
I'll be pissed off and I'll have to do
like a happy song or I'll be super happy
and I got to do like a really sad song
well yeah this stuff but then the
alternative though man yeah I see what
you're saying yeah he's he's able to
shift it yeah we're like if I'm just
like for example like I stopped blogging
for a long-ass time because you know
my you know things weren't going well in
my relationship and life and business
and family and everything right like I
felt like everything was crashing and
then to burn out everything added
together so I'm not even thinking like
how do I snap out of this I'm just like
in it and I'm just like [ __ ] man I know
I need to record right now but something
in my mind isn't like doing it it's so
weird like I could approach this when it
comes to working out so I think that's
the only stable thing that I had going
for me where I would like oh yeah I
still need to go to training once in a
while you know but I'm not going a
thousand percent so I don't know if you
guys go through the same thing too but
like when you're lost in the sauce and
you're just kind of too depressed or
angry or you're not in the right mindset
you'll go through the motions but you're
not giving it you're a thousand percent
for sure dude right when I when I look
back so I I admire you guys a lot
because you know guk like all the stuff
you do you guys are actually passionate
about and I think it shows why sometimes
we'll listen to like a random video I
did like five or six years ago and I'll
be like I worked really hard on this and
I like you know like now I kind of just
I don't do harmonies I'm gonna just do
it one time yeah that's good enough
whatever I just right now Jason yeah
okay I'm not passionate about it yeah
I'm not proud like any time some girls
like so what are you doing like nothing
yeah very hard right cuz even like me
like if I if I do music now it's because
I really like the project right and then
exactly like this the truck you did with
tim was super dope yeah yeah that's cuz
I really really enjoyed it but yeah you
know also there's other times too where
I know that people want to listen to
music so sometimes I'll do a track and I
and we're done recording it and I just
spent like a couple days on it and I
[ __ ] hate it and a part of me doesn't
want to put it out like I say 80% of me
doesn't to put it out but I know that
people want to hear something so I'll
just give to them anyways they might
like it yeah like there's a there's a
track that I did it was like an
old-school R&B joint and I was like I
don't really like this like I just and I
think like because I didn't like it as
much it felt like my heart wasn't into
it and it sounds like that on the track
so I don't really want to release it but
I think people want to hear it so why
not right and you know it's hard because
especially with doing covers for me the
reason what covers are hard is because
the the original artists I already liked
it already as it was so what am I going
to do to make this just different and
unique
like that song by some by summer Walker
I did send it girls need love I didn't
boys need love and I turned into like
this this like house R&B song first was
having to follow up with her [ __ ] right
which was hard enough as it was I
[ __ ] love that song but then how do I
do that
every week I don't know that's like
that's dope though so you guys are
changing songs up that you like yeah
what I'm doing is I'm just doing what
the charts say I should do yeah not
necessarily like people might not even
want to hear it mmm like how many people
actually want to hear me sing a Taylor
Swift song probably not that many but
you'd get a lot of views because they do
like it so not really I've accepted that
you know YouTube is not doing well for
me anymore so did the algorithms [ __ ]
you too because they used to they use I
feel it people blame the algorithm but I
feel like sometimes it's just because
I've been doing this for 10 years and I
haven't changed and there's like new
people coming up who have more resources
who care about who are more passionate
yeah so I'm sure part of its algorithm
but part of its probably just fatigue
like people are probably just not into
it anymore yeah right but the new thing
is kind of like trying to get a Spotify
playlist mm-hmm so it's just [ __ ]
hard yeah but then the Spotify playlist
stuff that does well doesn't do well on
YouTube exactly yeah so it's kind of
like picking your poison at the same
time though I'm just it just comes back
to being grateful and just like hey man
like this is better than complaining and
like doing a nine-to-five
so it's cool I mean that's very positive
because you're just like yeah I mean I
could I could go back to be an
accountant but I rather just do music
and it's like what's the real big deal
like yeah this song is just fun to do
yeah it's it might be a top-20 it might
not be like my favorite song but like
it's still just fun you know like it's a
fun song to do yeah pretty much yeah
it's it's hard I like I said music is
just one of those things that I think
that I mean one thing that you did very
well that I
I know that a lot of our friends who did
music that I was trying to get them to
understand was that the hard part about
music you know what a lot of musicians
do they leave their fate into the hands
of other people mean oh yeah for sure
you know I mean like so like for example
you can mix record and do everything by
yourself how many of our friends don't
that they can't yeah you control all the
sound so you can yeah so they're they're
kind of waiting on other people to do
things right and I never understood that
part it's like you understand that
YouTube is a space where you have to do
things yourself first and then you
create those opportunities well I don't
know any other musician that's as
organized and disciplined as a dis dude
yeah it's hard I mean Claire does her
own stuff too but but you know Claire's
probably more on this side where when
she gets fatigued she she has to take
that that artist break and then relax
and try to come back to it
the thing is Clara's brilliant though
yeah I mean like Clara's like crazy in
the artistic way yeah where she can pump
out some like crazy stuff she's inspired
so for her to do like covers every week
cuz I don't even change my covers man
like you have a system
I don't even change my that just making
an acoustic version so I can try getting
off playlists so it's like even more
dull but okay acoustics to it I mean the
reason why people like acoustics is
because there's like this raw thing to
it like I've realized that to like my my
best cover that I've ever done
apparently was just one track that I did
it was this ariana grande song and that
she's still is still climbing honeymoon
Avenue yeah that once that was that what
that was dope I almost lost my testicle
singing that song dude that [ __ ] was so
high man the people are you're seeing
that live impossible impossible that she
took so many [ __ ] takes but then that
one it still is an acoustic track is
than when I did the least amount of work
on butts the one that I like the most
yeah it's the one that do that that song
was really good and people were
listening that they even know that
ariana grande save I mean either look it
up yeah yeah so it was oh it was a
really fun track and now it's like now
I'm trying to experiment and do other
things with it but I I definitely still
like the acoustic stuff because it's so
raw like I like I like even as a
listener and a creator I like listening
to me to acoustic renditions because
it's so simple like a straight down
version of whatever all the production
is just stripped down yeah yeah I like
live performance acoustic but not so
much like the pop version like the fully
decked out like unless it's
at a club or summer it's so much easier
to record to pop stuff though yeah you
know there's this whole there's this
crew that's gating pop songs and all
that and making it like all funky scary
pockets yeah yeah AJ was on there
they're [ __ ] dope dude they're dope
too I don't think I'd be bored bored or
burned out if I did that no cuz every
single time
well they the thing is they keep the
novelty alive yeah I'm switching out bad
members singers and yeah I think I think
[ __ ] like that cuz I number one funk is
my favorite music genre mmm and then
what they'll do is they'll get like all
kinds of different musing us to do
different songs that are like from all
like genres like from R&B to like rock
to like whatever and then they make it
all funky yeah music is just so
difficult and I think that's what people
don't realize like how how hard music is
cuz there's so many moving parts to it
you know that obviously there's like a
like one of the hardest things that a
lot of people had to understand when
they were going into music that music
was never always just about music it has
never been there's always been a
business right and there's a way for you
to get your music out but a lot of
people didn't want to do that extra work
they just wanted to sing or they just
wanted to play their instruments and if
you want that's that's here's like I
think that's the bare minimum too
because if you think about it there's
all a lot of musicians yeah yeah I
thought are good I forgot who said this
it might have been like jay-z or it was
somebody really big right but they said
if you just did it for the love of the
music then you could have stayed like on
Santa Monica and you could have
performed your ass off and now I'd been
fine but you wanted to make this
artistry into a career well now it's a
business so now you're trying to play
this business game without doing the
business part and you're upset to why
you're not doing well makes no sense
because if you wanted to keep it for the
love of the art then that's fine too
but don't be upset when it doesn't pop
off the way you want to when you didn't
do your due diligence to make sure that
it worked off on the other end the part
that you're not experienced at and that
was that I think that's a hard part for
a lot of people whether it's music or
you know when we do comedy or anything
else it's hard for us to take this pill
and swallow it and say like okay I want
to do it because I love it but at the
same time we also just hate that
business side because it takes the fun
away from it the artist the artist is
conflicting with the manager yeah
and whoever said that I can't remember
if somebody can find that out but it was
like if you wanted to just do it for the
art then you should have just done it
for the art and left it at that but now
you're expecting this this Fame and
money to come along with it which it
wasn't a guarantee because you didn't
work this side at all
thank God I love both I think I think
I'm too much to the business side though
really yeah so I think I'm for the most
but I'm pretty self-aware I would say I
don't think any like artist would
respect me at all well it depends on who
you talk to because I bet you a lot of
artists envy what you have they might
envy me but they wouldn't respect me and
I'm the problem I have no problem are
you talking about like the music side of
things um like like if you're
technically well or like I mean cuz like
I I think a lot of artists can respect
your discipline and your approach to how
you how you do things if they're real
artists because if they understand the
work that that you do to get everything
together versus just your skill set
that's different that's a different
criteria right or like your how you how
you like create like I mean I think
that's two separate things yeah like
like um like maybe like you and Paul or
like Clara I would not judge any of you
guys or I know I would completely
understand if like you people like you
would be like or like dumbfounded
someone like that they would not be like
Jason's dough like they just like okay
yeah he works hard just discipline but
like and I get that you're also not
doing music in their genre so like if so
for example like other pop style YouTube
style musicians might I'm just saying as
someone who just has done covers for 10
years I know what you're saying oh it's
hard because I there is this stigma with
people who do a lot of covers versus
just doing original music it's like
waiting singers versus original artists
yeah yeah okay which for me I'm kind of
like half half on it because if you guys
have ever been to a [ __ ] concert like
these dudes perform 30% of their set is
other people's music like they'll do
covers like because it's like where else
do you think what the [ __ ] you think
takes work yeah essentially covers they
just covers before we're called mixtape
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was other people's beats
other people [ __ ] and you just did your
own thing to it and I think like that's
the hard part because there's two things
that come from in my personal opinion
one is jealousy right because you are it
let's say you know if that was the case
I they they want that level of success
that you had or have doing what they're
doing right now right but the reason why
covers do well is because people like to
see what somebody can do with something
that they're familiar with first and
then you bring in the original aspect -
I love cover music I [ __ ] love that
verse - like I I mean it's it's because
original music is very hard to do and
you can't do it repetitiously constantly
because it's hard to write music I've
been trying to write a song now for the
past three months and I still can't do
it the last time I wrote a song was like
[ __ ] like eight years ago that I
haven't done it [ __ ] since it's cuz
you don't work with me bro like I could
write I could write I can write I could
write pop music very easy though cuz pop
music is very formulaic - yeah right so
like I don't have to really think about
like those James Fauntleroy type of
lyrics yeah you know I mean like I just
had to sit there and just you know I
love you this is why I love you I met
you at this park I fell in love you what
the park and now we're in love
dn so when something repetitive and
catchy and yeah and it's really quick
like I I wrote like this pop song back
in the day and it was really dope but I
just couldn't sing it yeah so I used to
write music for other people all the
time but when it came to writing my own
music it was so [ __ ] difficult cuz I
want it to be something different you
know yeah so yeah I understand the whole
aspect of you thinking like look bet the
if you are very self-aware probably cuz
come on cover artists do get that a lot
do until I mean I don't even respect
what I do dude how come you never just
tried to sit down and kind of reinvent
yourself so this is the thing I was I
don't know about you guys but I mean you
guys are all around my age like 30 ish
younger a little bit over so now I feel
like I have different priorities like
I'm definitely not as ambitious as you
guys like I'm not ambitious
you guys are ambitious doing just trying
to reinvent yourself a new things and
that's a misinterpretation
I'm just a habitual hobby doer yeah me
and him are actually very very similar
in that
weird these serial hobby people I just
obsess over things that I get into and
when it's nice we move on yeah okay no
and and so like yeah I mean like I'm
like like for example like you know
David's been you know he made a feature
film he's got into Sundance and all this
stuff but like I could tell you that
that wasn't his thing to be a writer
actor director and that's his identity
you know what I mean so like when what
you see on the surface is it might be
like we're constantly doing things cuz
we're passionate but I'm just passionate
about life yeah like I don't I'll do it
if I was passionate about [ __ ] snap
collecting I would make that into an
obsession and turn that into a business
somehow or my next thing yeah when we
feel satisfied with it we'd go on to the
next one yeah like you haven't seen me
trying to make another film mmm and
people always ask is like yo why don't
you trying to be like the next big Asian
star out there oh good
if the opportunity comes great like I'm
still working on it but that checkbox of
make B do your own film has been checked
yeah you know so when people see
ambition I just see we just like life
and I'm not a gold chaser like goals are
awesome to have because goals just give
you some type of direction to where you
go but I don't validate my self-worth in
accomplishments I just like to do things
yeah because there's always gonna be
someone above you and below you and if
you're constantly trying to measure
yourself up out in the world or like you
need to like hit these goals or else
you're not worth something like I feel
like that's a that's just like a destiny
to depression and failure like another
example is you know you know people ask
me like how come you haven't you know
done the full like stand-up comedy tour
cuz I've been doing stand-up now for so
long you know and when I was doing these
college shows they'd be like thousands
of people there and okay so why do I
have to go to the Dave Chappelle route
you know I've gotten what I want out of
this I'll still do stand-up I still do
stand-up now but I'm doing it because I
enjoy it like I don't have this singular
goal anymore of being like the best
stand-up comedian on earth that used to
be my goal when I first started out but
then I started finding out like when I
started doing bigger and bigger shows
it doesn't make me happy like I think I
got what I wanted out of this right so
Meadows on to the next one then we
started doing food businesses right and
that's where the passion is right now
like I like doing food foods fun yeah so
now it's like well this is my next
target goal is to make sure that these
food things pop off so until the food
stuff like really pops off I'm I can't
move on from it yet so I wanna I want to
be the best unknown youtuber the best
unknown one yeah the [ __ ] I am but like
people that do watch me they enjoy it
yeah so I was gonna get to like right
now what I treasure most is kind of like
free time and just time to kind of do
what I want to do not post it about so
you're probably in the stage where you
are kind of screaming to reinvent
yourself because you're just trying to
find that next thing of what you care
about kind of yeah you know yeah do you
do you think that's still within music
it could be but maybe it doesn't have to
be for me I have like a like a
fulfillment checklist so like one would
be just like a hobby that is sacred to
me that I won't turn into a business and
I just do it for me and that's martial
arts or karate and but that's a physical
fulfillment right I have I have to have
like an emotional expressing fulfillment
which is gonna be it's always been music
I just play piano or whatever and I
don't have to perform it or sell it or
anything
another one is business fulfillment
right like I enjoy making money and
that's really fun but I can't paint
I'm never going to taint my like karate
and other things with these things right
because I've done it before and once you
mix it it just gets all [ __ ] up yep
because I think like for you too I know
this happens with music a lot and it's
not like what you're particularly going
through with your music it's very unique
to your estate right look how many times
[ __ ] Kanye West has reinvented
himself
mhm every album he reinvents himself
right because he can't go back and do
the same thing over and over again
because with your music I feel like that
you you can do a lot of things that you
haven't done yet right like it's it's so
you've you've done this whole route your
whole life like number one with your
voice specifically you have an ability
to see what
you want I actually don't have that I
have an ability to sing what I can write
it's because number one your your
control of your voice is really great
actually I can't I can't sing the R&B
stuff like you can though you really can
you just have to get in you just don't
you take classes yeah yes clown
just have to listen to it more and you
have to get into it more that's all that
it really takes it's like really likes
its reps it's like some even for me I
have a very limited amount of runs I
could probably do more if i sat there
listen to more and I practiced yeah but
I choose not to right so that's the same
thing for you if you really start to
love that music you have certain artists
that you like then you follow them my
runs are literally based off anything
Brian midnight does because I love
Brightman night so much like my falsetto
is literally a copy of Brian the nice
ball senator so I had these artists that
I emulate that I like you said to find
that for yourself too if pop music is
not the stuff that really makes you sit
then be like yo this is dope and maybe
yeah I feel like if you just find the
music that you connect to that you
genuinely connect to and then you can
express yourself truly through that the
reinvention might be really just finding
who Jason always was and then you can
write accordingly um I think I just want
to do more business like music I got
like that with JK yeah I got too much
like fun out and I was like it's time to
approach this and make it into a
business and it was so fun doing that
while I kept doing the comedy stuff but
yeah I think like you're at that point
where you're like alright I just maybe
want to take away it do other business
maybe I might need some time focus on
other stuff before I can kind of
reinjure music again because right now
every time I listen to music I'm just
kind of like I'm trying to figure out
what sounds are using that's relevant
what they're you know like I'm analyzing
it and why it might be good let's get so
it's it's like I don't even enjoy it I'm
kind of just listening to it and I have
to like focus on like the elements of it
I'm trying to like reverse engine I'm
trying to Kevin Durant yeah bring
basically yeah and
it's it's not fun it's like it's boring
so I try to do a lot of hobbies that I
don't want to vlog about I mean I might
later on but because it's kind of like
what you said like once you get any kind
of business or kind of any other
incentives involved it just sucks yeah
like I go I go work out with Bart just
because I like I I want to see if I can
do it just because like yeah it's like
so horrible that I want to see if I can
make it out live
Bart's program oh when I go work out
with Bart I have I get like pretty
destroyed man oh yeah yeah you guys make
it through okay I don't ever go there
ever no I've been there a couple times
and it's the worst experience of my life
yeah it's pretty bad it's actually much
lighter now than what it used to be
damn yeah well yeah his [ __ ] was pretty
[ __ ] rough dude I'd be debilitated
yeah it's pretty it's pretty difficult
but that's that's cool though cuz I know
for me like when it comes to hobbies
there's things that I like that's why I
hated vlogging like I I used to vlog I
hate for it that's why I don't have a
lot of instance stories like I almost
don't know how to do it now
cuz I when I'm when I'm hot in the
moment I'm just in the moment in the
moment past I'm like [ __ ] I should have
recorded that [ __ ] you know that's why
when I do I have a patreon now and I'm
doing these life logs I do it solely
because they enjoy it and I understand
that they they want to see this so it
makes me happy to think of a creative
way to create something for these people
who are supporting me that's why I do it
then you know but you know even within
the patreon people are very supportive
and they understand that I'm just
creating just to want to really create
and that's where I get to test a lot of
my stuff like I've done vlogs now where
the format changed like three or four
times already and I'm just seeing if
they like it and because they're my
tester pool but super dope yeah I like
vlogging I tried patreon like twice and
it never worked so I just gave up okay
guys surprise support my patreon make
new music I got like three backers like
I forget we have a lot of people just
looking for the music and then there's a
video yeah
so mostly your fans are just like coming
through clicking and listening yeah yeah
probably yeah so that's why you got to
start blogging so people understand who
the real Jason is it's tough too oh yeah
I mean business man I mean that what you
want to do in business real estate
anything dude I mean really stop
looking at real estate just cause
interest rates are so low be really dope
to get like some rental property now
that won't like where the property value
won't fluctuate and matter that much in
the crash
but I don't know but that's pretty fun
for me actually like looking at property
you know finance YouTube is like killing
it right now you know that gray gray I'm
Stephen Graham Stephen yeah yeah that
stuff was getting like I don't know like
$17 CPM or some [ __ ] yeah it's pretty
nuts it's pretty awesome you know I'm
not too lewd for YouTube I think I think
YouTube hates me I think they just like
it it has to be very clean and precise
I'm I'm very I'm a very lewd person
let's be very brand friendly very ah
[ __ ] that dude I can't do it I will
shoot myself in the [ __ ] face dude I
feel like there's gonna be a time when
the bots are gonna be so good they could
cure the conversation and be like flag
flag flag doesn't matter you guys got
patron oh right oh I still need more
patreon doesn't cover everything yeah
patreon like like honestly the money
that I'm getting from patreon literally
only pays for the people to edit these
videos that's really about it
yeah like it's it's it's not some like
egregious amount of money and whoever
supports I'm very grateful for it like
if there's a like literally if if I
didn't have to have a patreon I wouldn't
have never opened a patreon right but
people like uncensored content and if I
can't change that format then I need I
need financial help because other than
that I'm not gonna make money because
even if it does get monetized it's the
lowest amount of CPM ever the lowest so
you know I had to make that adjustment
and you know the people who are
supporting it now it's keeping this
channel afloat is keeping this going cuz
it's not that I could say thank you guys
yeah so thank you very much [ __ ] man
well guys that's an hour and dude we
were wrapping up that podcast you guys
can catch us on Spotify stitch or iTunes
Jason where can they find you Spotify
iTunes Jason Chen Jason Chen and music
extraordinaire five-foot-one of all sexy
Chinese Taiwanese goodness you guys
could if you guys see us on iTunes give
us that five star and then yeah guys
we'll see you guys next time
thank you very much peace [ __ ]